my name is Kayla ward I went from
ministry and the church to finally
living my truth as a trans woman who was
going to try out with the WNBA and this
is that story I honestly don't remember
the first time I picked up a basketball
but I do remember having one of those
little tight goals those plastic ones
and my mom will go out there and shoot
around with me I was probably like free
three or four and I remember getting
that first point where I was like would
run up and dunked on it and I broke it
and landed on my head but that didn't
deter me like I loved it I was so
excited that I was able to do that from
there I would sneak away into the inner
city when I was young as seven and I
would play basketball and it's just
where I would go every day I was down
every day that the thoughts wouldn't
leave my mind of how I felt inside my
earliest memories of really feeling like
it wasn't this boy as everybody said I
was was when I was around five or six I
remember in particular probably a little
graphic but going to take a bath one day
and just really not liking what was on
my body I really wanted to take a knife
and cut it off it was just something
that was telling me that this wasn't
right and as I got older and I was
around more people especially other
girls I was like that's supposed to be
me and it wasn't necessarily playing
with dolls or the dresses cuz I'm still
not very girly I'm not very feminine I
don't wear a lot of makeup I'd rather be
on a basketball court so it's it's hard
to say what moment was really that
trigger it was just a feeling inside
that told me who I was
it was difficult feeling like you didn't
belong or fit in so it's a lot about
putting on a front I was an amazing
actor for 30 years especially as a kid
because kids are very intuitive they
pick up on things
just why I really push so hard to sports
it's hard to really pinpoint something
different about a jock I guess how I
related was just through sports and then
eventually through religion I joined a
youth group at church found new friends
and every time the doors to the church
were open I was there I was involved in
every every activity every Bible study
just looking for answers I found myself
really praying hard for the feelings I
had internally to go away I felt a sense
of belonging that I'd never felt before
with the church and the family that I
had so I decided I wanted to give my
life over and make that a career went to
about this college to pursue youth
ministry or mission work while I was
doing this mission work I did find
somebody that I fell in love with they
became my best friend
and I thought this is just God's
direction everything's going according
to plan I'm gonna be this wonderful
husband I'll eventually be a father
and it'll all work out we were together
for 10 years married for seven the last
three years of the marriage kind of
started to fall apart
there was there was division between my
wife and I it was kind of dressing on
the side and trying to come to terms
with myself and finding community on
mine she would almost catch me every
time and I would lie about it so I
remember her asking for a divorce and it
broke me
we were Christian we what we were
married I'm just told that's to be part
we weren't supposed to get divorced so I
begged her to stay I said we'll try
counseling whatever she said it's not
gonna happen when she moved out it's
kind of when I really hit
I was done I really was I didn't want to
put anybody else through what I felt
like I've heard through I didn't feel my
parents would accept her understand so I
thought what else do I have to lose I
might as well just end it so I had a
bottle of pills but I was just gonna
down it was night and the house was dark
and I was just crying my face was in my
hands and in my pillow and I was scared
to do it but I was ready and my cats
they would never be near each other but
they both in that moment we're climbing
up on my lap trying to push my hands
away they were licking the tears one on
each side and it
it made it even harder because I was so
ready but I didn't want to lose my
babies their attention and love to me is
what really kind of kept me here not
feeling alone was probably the most
important part
I threw the bottle of pills away and it
was the next day that I started seeing a
gender therapist started hormones and
began loving my truth I called my dad
crying and really scared because he
always called me his butt and told me
how proud he was of me and they want to
lose that and he assured me that he left
me no matter what I was his kid and that
when I remarried one day he would walk
me down the aisle so that was reassuring
it really helped move me forward know
when I called my mom completely
different story she was pissed so we had
an argument I told her she couldn't use
the right pronouns or call me by the
right name or even just say my child
that I wouldn't be able to talk to her
I'd have to kind of cut that out and so
we didn't talk for two years and it
wasn't until I visited again where she
introduced me to her co-workers as her
daughter so it took some time and I
learned a lot too that that sometimes
we're not the only ones transitioning
those around us our friends and our
family are going through the same thing
it's a shock to them and they kind of
have to come along the journey with you
and it's not always gonna be smooth
sailing I lost a lot of the friends
initially that we're connected to me and
my ex-wife we did go to a Baptist
College together so everybody really
disagreed with who I am my views of the
church now are completely different I
still have this personal faith the
church today is problematic and stepping
away from it allowed me to see that more
they're completely missing the point
the Bible specifically talks a lot about
love and most people have no idea what
that really means or how to provide that
to other people
it took a little time to come out at
work but I was actually surprised a lot
of people are very accepting and
supportive and pushed me a lot to break
out of my comfort zone and stop being so
shy and nervous moved to Dallas Texas
for a few years I met a lot of amazing
people which that turn led to LA because
I really wanted to pursue my passion in
2021 I want to try out for the WNBA so
unfortunately a lot of leagues don't
have guidelines that allow trans people
to play however the International
Olympic Committee does have a policy if
you are a trans woman you have to be
living in your true gender for at least
a year you have to be on HRT hormone
replacement for at least a year and you
have to test consistently for 12 months
at a testosterone level of 10 or below
they are changing that testosterone
level to 5 or below because cisgender
women usually range between one and two
some can produce higher so for those who
consistently say that it's not an even
playing field when say a trans woman
joins assists women's league I
transitioned seven years ago I don't
produce testosterone I lost a lot of
muscle mass so if I were to compete
against men now especially in a
professional level I would just get
demolished and thrown around the court
like a rag doll when it comes to trans
people in sports it honestly breaks down
to almost a case by case scenario
because there are requirements of living
in your gender for a year and have
been on HRT for a year so as long as
those things are in place I would say
trans people should be allowed to play
the sport of their choosing in the
gender that matches her identity I have
no problems hearing opposing views
because it's important at the dialogue
Sports is about community it's about
connecting it's about not feeling
isolated alone it provides this sense of
belonging and so everywhere from little
kids all the way up to adults we need
that if I'm honest I have a better
chance of winning a lottery while being
struck by lightning and I say that not
because of my skill level but I'm 37 so
by the time I try out I'll be 39 so not
exactly young and I've blown out of me
I've damaged my back I've had
concussions so my body may not let me
play but it's not the only goal I have
if I don't get to make it if I can
create the policy that allows other
people to follow their dreams that's a
win when I grew up we didn't have the
internet we didn't have social media
there was no trans representation on TV
for as long as I could remember I felt
like there was just something wrong with
me I was a freak so now seeing so many
people living their lives out and proud
that means everything I have people all
over probably more or less the Midwest
in the south who reach out who
understand my story because they're
married or they're in a relationship
they're in the church they have kids and
they feel trapped so I get to help
provide that vision of what life can be
if they just allow themselves to be
for me life is just beautiful when you
aren't having to hide who you are so I
can say the biggest difference between
before and now is I'm free if I could
talk to my younger self I would tell
that little kid that it's okay you may
not understand everything now you may
feel afraid and alone but I promise you
you're not life can be beautiful it can
be worth living you can make friends you
don't have to be alone and you'd be
surprised at how many people will
actually accept you and love you as who
you are so you have to let go of that
self hate because you think it's gonna
come from people outside and it's not
going to not the way you think most of
that comes from yourself so you have to
let that go breathe and let yourself be
[Music]